تقول القاعده العامه في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الامريكيه انك لا تستطيع الفوز
اذا لم تفز باوهايو لم يتمكن اي رئيس
امريكي من كسر هذه القاعده منذ جون كندي
الا مرشح الوحيد جويدا عام 2020 رغم ذهاب
اوهايو الى ترامب
مجددا تصبح اوهاي محطه الانظار في
الانتخابات النصفيه خصوصا في التنافس على
مجلس الشيوخ
السنه الجمهوري روبرت بورتمان الذي ضل في
مقعد سنه لولايتين قرر عدم الترشح مجددا
ليفتح باب منافسه شرسه بين الحزبين
الجمهوريون يريدون الاحتفاظ بالمقعد في
سعيهم للسيطره على مجلس الشيوخ
والديمقراطيون يريدون اضافه المقعد لهم
لنفس السبب
يتنافس على منصب السيناتور رجل الاعمال
والمحامي والمؤلف الجمهوري جيدفانس وعضو
مجلس النواب الديمقراطي
لكن السباق يشبه انتخابات الرئاسه
الامريكيه لعام 2016 حيث يدعم دونالد
ترامب وبكل قوه
ترامب دائما صاحب الحضور الطالب
مزاج هناك يميل قليلا الى الجمهوريين